[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
george campbell your host joined today
by dr john deloney and we would love to
talk to you
maybe you've got some questions about
some things happening in your life here
at a crossroads you need some
confirmation you need a third party
opinion maybe we are here for you give
us a call the number is triple eight
eight two five
five two two five phone lines are open
and some say the advice is worth what
you pay for it what do you think john
i agree with that yeah we're in full
agreement there i agree with that ryan
kicks us off this hour in charlotte
north carolina ryan welcome to the
ramsay show
hey sorry i'm a little bit nervous but i
figured i'd call in real quick and hey
george is real nervous right so
intimidating you're in good company
brother you'll do great we're here for
you man how can we help
hey um
one the main question is
i don't really know anything about cash
out refinancing and is there ever a
situation where
you would you would say it's okay to do
that if you were remodeling a home to
make it bigger
versus going out and just purchasing a
larger home and taking out the mortgage
anyway it would be that size
oh you're saying instead of going and
buying a new house to upgrade
should i just do the cash out refi and
do the renovations at the house i'm
currently in
right but i don't really know anything
about cash out refund is that
essentially the same thing as a heloc or
i mean i know they're not the same thing
but would it be the same fee would it be
even remotely something that you would
consider saying okay to do
yeah well what's your situation right
now
is that just what you're trying to do
you're wondering if we should remodel
yeah because we got a 19 1950 square
foot house
and it's just getting really cramped
we've got two kids
and it's we could add another 500 square
feet to it because we have an attached
carport it would look exactly like the
house so it's something that's
definitely something that we've
considered
but is it something that we even want to
go down the road because we
we follow the plan so we don't want to
we would we're in 456
so
it's really just a matter of is this
something that you because we don't have
the cash to do it so is it something
that you would even suggest doing
to get the cash out to be able to to
remodel the home sure well with any
refinance there's going to be closing
costs and so yes it will cost you money
and personally i wouldn't do it i would
save up over time and pay for those
renovations
is that going to be too difficult for
you guys right now
well right now we got two in daycare and
the budget's already tight enough with
the 15
so it's going to be at least two years
before we can start saving a good amount
of money because daycare is just so
expensive right this minute so it's not
and it's not really a necessity it's
just one of those things where we would
like to do it so i just don't know
enough about it to
say cash out refinance would be an
option because obviously i don't want to
add any more debt to the mortgage but
it's something that
i don't know enough about to say
is that even something that that dave
would say it's okay to do do you uh
let's take the interest rates off and i
know i'll get some heat about this but
would you put 60 000 bucks on a credit
card to do what you're about to do
no absolutely not right and so
i want you to think of it as i know
if you put it in a more if you roll it
up into a new mortgage and just a a
a cash refi simply you're going to
refinance your house that let's say it
cost a hundred thousand dollars and
you're gonna go refinance a hundred and
forty thousand dollars and you're gonna
take that cash you can take that 40
grand and you're gonna invest it into
your house right
so right i would prefer you to think of
it as just a credit card as you're
taking on debt to complete a house
project and here's why
the number of people if you look back
over the last two years
just scan social media right a that's
going to make you less intelligent if
you do that let's be clear but go ahead
and do that and look at the number of
people who have run into
building issues the cost of the
renovation went up halfway through it it
went down it went up people went off the
job they quit
at the end of the day that bill is still
due
if you take out debt for this project if
you're cash flowing this project you can
stop you can pause you can wait until
these so the timelines are annoying
they're not catastrophic you hear what
i'm saying
right so i i know may i have a two
little ones it's dude everything feels
like you were living in the middle of a
tornado and that you feel like that 500
square foot would be a game changer and
it would be
what i don't want you to do in this
unstable environment
economically is to take on 40 50 60 000
debt of a remodel and then suddenly
something happens and that bills come
and do no matter what
yeah
yeah i just i didn't really know
anything about what that is for one and
then also if that would even be
you're refinancing and they give you a
pile of cash and you go further into
debt yeah so the idea is if you had if
you have a mortgage on a 200 000 house
and it's worth half a million dollars
they want you to take out a bigger refi
for that you know what i'm saying and
you can spend that money on a new roof
or new game or whatever so they're going
to just hand you cash but they're going
to it's going to roll up into a new
mortgage
yeah
there's t-logs and stuff like that which
are absolutely not not an option but
same thing i didn't know anything about
it yeah just taking the same thing here
at the end of the day ryan this is it's
a shortcut and i know you got a lot
going on you went man we can just get
this stuff done with a quick refinance
and life will be great but remember you
guys worked so hard to get through baby
step one two and three now you're in
four five six i wanna see you pay off
that home i wanna see you become a baby
steps millionaire and it's going to be a
lot harder taking this step backwards
doing a cash out refi to get these
renovations done versus sacrificing
doing what it takes maybe you are
working extra under some long nights
long days in the season but man when you
pay for those renovations with cash it's
going to mean a lot more and it's not
going to set you guys back with your
progress
okay
i know i know he said he's like well
that's not what i was like you two guys
are the worst you'll ruin my life thanks
you idiots no i i mean it's not even a
necessity thing that we were just in the
beginning stage of us discussing it and
it was one of those things like you're
in four five six do you really want to
go into that situation and then the
conversation was brought up about going
and purchasing a larger home well that's
even more mortgage anyway right so it
was that was a that was a sticking point
we're like well i don't really know
actually now that you say that how old
are your little ones i just figured i'd
call and ask them ask the experts anyway
how old are your little ones
uh two and four two and four
i'll just tell you i haven't been there
everything feels chaotic and when things
get chaotic is when we often start
either a compromising on our
our values or we start looking like
george said for shortcuts or okay let's
just try this or what about this looks
like a good plan
just go back to the basics
don't owe anybody any money
and don't take out uh money that's not
yours don't let somebody sweet talk you
into borrowing money from them in order
to get a uh something right now that you
think is gonna feel better right this
second because that two-year fort dude
very few things make life with a two and
a four year old feel less chaotic
even when they're on top of each other
even when they're driving each other
crazy making bedtimes hard all that's
just crap everywhere i get it
don't borrow money just stop stop right
leave let that be the end of the
conversation there you know what's gonna
happen now john ryan's phone just heard
him talking about cash out refunds it's
gonna be showing him ads for days on end
oh about how this is the solution to all
of his problems that's right that's
right that's how this works you got to
say no to the distractions and know what
are the traps you know the plan man stay
on the course cash flow everything your
life will be better for it
open phones this hour give us a call
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll talk about your life your
money relationships boundaries mental
health we are here for you america and
we would love to talk to you this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
so
welcome back you are listening to the
ramsay show i'm ramsey personality
george campbell joined by my great
friend some might say best friend dr
john deloney are we great friends no i
don't think we are at all actually it
was a good effort though
i like i like that you're going for it
i'm trying i'm seeing what'll stick with
you so far uh no bueno we're not friends
but we i think we will get there one day
well you know who is my friend hannah in
tacoma washington who happens to be
joining us right now on the show hannah
how are you doing
i'm good how are you great how can john
and i help today
um i was just calling me and my partner
just got engaged and he actually just
told me about the baby steps maybe three
weeks ago congratulations and welcome to
the game and
so i have my thousand dollar starter
fund and
i've paid off two credit cards in the
last three weeks way to go
way to go
thank you the reason for my call is i
know you guys say don't combine your
finances until you're actually married
correct which is completely
understandable but i was wondering since
i'm the one with debt and he's debt free
would it be
kind of skipping steps if i had him save
up our three to six months emergency
fund because we do live together
um we just don't have like joint
accounts or anything and then i continue
to pay off my debt by myself
while he
does our three to six month emergency
fund is that
when are you guys getting married
um
well we're going through pre-marital
counseling right now and we haven't
picked a for sure date but we were
thinking about doing like a courthouse
elopement now and then have a real
wedding later when there's a little less
covet and a little more savings
a little more savings i like it
so here's the thing you were right that
you guys should not combine finances and
here's the thing you are on your own
journey right now in the baby steps
paying off your debt he's on his own
journey debt-free building up his
emergency fund and so this is not a our
situation yet and so if if i'm him i'm
just saving up my emergency fund and
when it comes time for us to get married
well guess what we are now in baby step
2 paying off our debt
right are y'all how do y'all split the
bills up right now
um we do
the susie i can't remember her last name
it's like this mathematical equation
where you figure out your percentages
susie orman's pythagorean theorem
so
yeah something like that was ours not
good enough for you
no how do you how do you determine who
pays what bill
oh well we add all of the bills that are
our bills so like internet rent for the
apartment we both live in and stuff like
that we just add that up and then we
find out
the percentage based on who makes what
amount of money oh wow so it's skewed if
you if he makes more money he has a
bigger share of the bills
correct interesting even if
even if you like just leave the lights
on all over the house see how this gets
messy real fast
yeah where this makes way more sense and
we get pushback from all over the place
makes
way more financial sense
marital sense
and it makes way more partnership sense
like you and i are in this together
because we got married is to put all of
your accounts when you get married put
all your account put all of your money
into the same account
and everything comes out of there when
you start dividing up responsibilities
by who makes more and who doesn't last
and all that is a marital recipe for a
relationship implosion because you're
always going to be saying well i did
dinner well then you should you know we
always have that one for him this is
before venmo of course we always had
that one friend that would be like hey
uh you owe me four dollars 28 cents i
got wendy's like four years ago and
you're like what do you talk that's what
our marriages turn into when we live
like that i love your idea of
running to the courthouse and getting
married and starting from scratch here
and just saying all right we're all
putting all of our money together every
month we're combining it there will be
seasons when you make more he makes more
whatever it is and then we're gonna
build that out of that together right i
love that place right how much debt do
you have left
uh i have a i got it down from 37 000 to
i think it's like 36
and some change okay um right now and
i make 35 000 a year right now but i am
lucky to have gotten a job right before
the pandemic where we have a union
negotiated 50 cent raise every six
months
so it's steadily climbing up every six
months and then i am in line right now
to actually
change positions
sometime maybe the next six months which
would change my pay grade on the scale
very cool okay awesome
well good luck hannah congrats on the
engagement but hey stick to the journey
on your own until you guys are married
and things will be better for it yeah so
right now
just to refresh until you all get
married you need to have your emergency
fund he's got to have his emergency fund
and right now you are dumping everything
on cash and he's going to take an
emergency fund out of his whatever
magical percentage you'll have come up
with and they uh yeah the new the new
you've never heard of that mathematical
formula
that's just like that would cause a lot
of resentment i can't even tell you i
just feels like such a disaster
but anyway all right here we are amanda
from tampa joins us next let's see what
amanda has to say welcome to the ramsay
show
thanks
um my question is i kind of did think
backwards i'm a young single mom and i
just bought my first home back in
february so it'll be a year next month
um
it was kind of a rush thing with either
rent again or buy a home
and so i bought it and but i'd still
have some i have a car debt and um who
you credit card debt
but i um have a twenty five hundred
dollars in savings and i have a 401k
and i didn't know where to go to next
because i kind of went all over the
place on the baby set
so you want to refocus and go hey i know
i'm doing too much at once how do i
start making progress
yeah and so i did um
i did just get a job offer and become a
project engineer that gives me a pay
increase
of almost twelve thousand dollars for
annual income um it's now 55k a year
salary great um on what i was making now
i did graduate college back in august uh
with no
no debt to school at all
so um so what's your total debt right
uh my total debt is
my car i owe about eight but i'm paying
that off with my taxes so that'll be
done you got a refund coming in
yeah so that'll be
gone i'm using the whole thing to pay
off my car and then i have like less
than a thousand dollars in credit card
debt very good so you had 9 000 total
about
yeah and you'll be debt-free here the
next few months right
correct okay sidebar stop getting a
refund uh change your withholdings work
with your employer on that because the
government's just hanging on to your
money interest-free right now so i love
that it's knocking out your debt but
that was your money and so you could
have been using that all year long to
become debt free versus waiting until
now so let's refocus this thing you're
going to be debt-free in a few months
correct and you have 2500 in savings so
let's go ahead and knock out that credit
card debt today
okay
and then we're going to knock out this
car debt once this refund comes through
then we're gonna be working on uh baby
step three so we're gonna save up three
to six months of expenses and you're
gonna pause investing right now so that
you can do that you said you're
investing in your 401k
yeah i invest like five dollars it's not
much i just throw it like five minutes
literally five dollars
yeah i just whatever is in my wow throw
it in there and not forget it i just
forgot i can't even do that
it's like a spare change no i don't
think okay well well well positive round
up to the 401k yes i would well done so
you've got this great new income and i
want to make sure that we use it wisely
so very quickly this is going to take
you less than six months i want you to
save up three to six months of expenses
and then you can start investing again
and when you do it's not going to be
five dollars because you have all the
margin now don't you you don't have a
car payment you don't have credit card
payments so you can now invest 15
of that 55 000 into your 401k
okay you see what i'm doing here and you
feel the progress you're like wow if i
just do this stuff
in order one at a time
i feel like i'm winning
yeah it's it's like when you used to
watch old uh
videos of punt returners in a football
game that would run 60 yards back and
forth and they would never get anywhere
down the field oh yeah and then you'd
see some folks just put their head down
and run and then they
make progress progress progress progress
if i had a nickel for every punt return
i've watched john i would have less than
a nickel i'll tell you that much right
now zero nickels
thanks for the question amanda this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
hey folks it's time to put 2021 behind
us
february starts tomorrow can you believe
that last year left a lot of people
feeling burned out and sluggish eeyore
was their spirit animal but 2022 is a
fresh start and this is your wake-up
call if you're ready to own this here
and actually accomplish your goals with
money your career and life we've got a
plan to get you there
you can make 2022 your best year yet
right now we're running our new year's
sale so you can get up to 73 off our
best-selling books assessments and
envelopes that includes dave's brand new
number one national best-selling book
baby steps millionaires that will show
you the quickest right way to become a
millionaire or if you're looking for a
better way to manage your cash
especially in categories that always
blow up your budget like food pick up
our popular essential cash envelope
systems maybe you're having a hard time
bouncing back from the last two wild
years well you could start 2022 off with
our best selling quick read from my
friend dr john deloney redefining
anxiety so you can learn what anxiety is
what it's not and how to get your life
back best part is it's only 10 bucks so
visit the online store at
ramseysolutions.com
store to get serious and make real
progress but hurry the sale ends today
that's right it ends today karen joins
us in san antonio karen welcome to the
ramsay show
hi um first time calling so i'm very
awesome here bye a little nervous but um
pigmentation and
some money a little bit and hold on
carolyn hold on speak directly on your
phone for me i'm having a hard time
hearing you
okay i am debt free awesome and i have
come into some inheritance money
and uh
who passed away
i'm sorry who passed away
my father-in-law i'm sorry
thank you
uh
would like to know what's the best way
to make more money from this money how
should i invest the best way
gotchas how much money is it
35
and you said that you
have no debt i didn't hear about your
house do you have a mortgage note too
no no i'm definitely on my own home on
my own car
and i'm a retirement of about sixty
thousand
okay how old are you on t i double a
correct
how old are you karen
59 59. okay when did he when did your
father-in-law pass away
this past july this past july i'm sorry
well let's talk about this money so you
have a paid for home you don't have a
lot in retirement do you have any other
retirement out there what's your what's
your game plan on that side
no that's all i have okay but you
managed to have a paid for house so
that's awesome you've no payment in the
world yeah
okay well this is good news so if i'm
you you've got a fully funded emergency
fund in place
no
you don't how much do you have in
savings outside of this 35 000
inheritance
uh probably about 1200.
okay
well congratulations you know have an
emergency fund yeah there you go
how can i make more money off this money
to put away for
for retirement or anything that should
happen well you don't make money from
the emergency fund because it's
insurance it's not an investment
and right now if something goes out if
the hvac goes out on the house how are
you going to pay for that
oh i guess my savings i don't know you
don't have savings you just told me you
had twelve hundred dollars to your name
right well that's my savings yes yeah so
that's what i'm saying is i want this to
become your emergency fund so that when
life happens you don't have to go
backwards into debt which is going to
help you by the way build wealth and
retire with dignity do you still work
yes what's your income
about 35 to 40 000 a year okay and do
you have much margin at the end of the
month since you don't have a mortgage
payment how much money would you say you
could scrounge up at the end of the
month if you got tight on the budget
about 800 okay do you have a 401k
through your work
no
so no retirement one
yeah they don't offer one the only thing
i have is my uh
my ti double a
50 about 58 000. okay 9000.
well i would be investing into whatever
option you have you can also do an ira a
roth ira is a great option that's going
to help your money grow tax-free so i
would be maxing that out every single
year as long as you're working
with the money that you have coming in
from your paycheck but the inheritance
is going to be your emergency fund i
don't want you to invest that because
this just saved you by the way about six
months or more of saving up for this
emergency fund uh with the blessing of
this inheritance that came into your
life
and what is the normal amount for
emergency fund
we we say three to six months of
expenses so take one normal month of
expenses and multiply that by three or
six in your situation are you single
yeah
okay so i would lean towards six because
your income is all you have if you if
your job goes away tomorrow you we need
to make sure that you've got that big
umbrella to carry you through until you
find something else
and then i want you to get in a regular
rhythm of putting
for a season couple of years take that
800 a month and begin dumping everything
into your retirement accounts now you
are fully funded in your emergency fund
you're bulletproof now and then you can
begin to really double down on these
retirement accounts um and that is going
to grow money and grow money and grow
money i can hear your disappointment
that you thought we were going to give
you some
quick account that was going to
like double or triple this 30 000 bucks
do you hear what george is saying about
it's just a matter of time before you
roll an ankle or your car transmission
falls out or you need to redo a hole in
the roof and then suddenly you're going
to a bank or getting a credit card again
do you hear that okay yeah yeah i gotcha
being able to sit on this you might be
able to sleep for the first time in a
long time just having peace that
if come what may bill's wise that you're
going to be able to just get to the next
month it's just gonna be annoying it's
just gonna be a frustrating annoying
thing it's not gonna be catastrophic or
you're gonna have to go get a credit
card out again
so karen let's say your monthly expenses
are four thousand dollars a month we
multiply that by six we get a 24 000.
we'll call it 25 so you can feel good so
this inheritance 25 of that i'm gonna
park in a savings account i'm not gonna
touch it i'm gonna let it sit there and
it's not gonna make you any money and
that's okay because it's there to
protect us now the extra five ten
thousand dollars i if i'm you i'm going
to fully fund a roth ira for the year
and let that money grow right away 10 15
20 years so that is something you can do
right now that will help you make that
money and you can connect with a smart
investor pro that's our financial
advisors that are trained the ramsey way
you can trust them they have a heart of
a teacher and they can walk you through
that process if you need someone to kind
of hold your hand through this
as you head into retirement i want to
make sure that the money you have coming
in we are very wise with it
okay and i can find that information on
the ramsey website yes jump on
ramsaysolutions.com you can click on
trusted pros there and you'll see the
investment side and our smartvestor pros
we've got one in your area in san
antonio that would be happy to help you
uh and there let me tell you they're
gonna make you make the decision they're
not gonna tell you what to do they're
gonna show you your options so that you
are educated and can make a decision
that's right for you
but you do have to get really
intentional about using your your access
money every month
and putting it towards retirement how
long you plan on working okay
well i'd like to quit from today but
i i don't think that's possible um i
don't know probably another five ten
years i guess so here's what's great
about sitting down with the smartvestor
pro and i did it the first time and it
was it was eye opening is they just help
you reverse engineer
if you retire at this age here's how
much money you're gonna need and if you
put this much money away every month
times what we think it's gonna do in the
market and of course we're just guessing
like everybody else is but they're
better guessers than i am um here's what
you're gonna need so you get to deal in
actual data actual facts right not just
well i'd like to quit but i can't so
i'll just keep plugging along it gives
you an a a guided path towards where you
want to go with your money
good stuff from karen there this is a
question we get a lot john what do i do
with the inheritance with this blessing
that someone that was near and dear to
me
left to me and one of the best things
you can do is be a good steward of it
yeah is to manage it wisely is to filter
it through the baby steps to set
yourself up for financial freedom so you
don't have to worry you have options
and
i want to do that to my kids i want to
leave them at a better place than i was
and that's exactly what the inheritance
does for people and i hope that karen
can retire with dignity and sleep easy
at night knowing she's got an emergency
fund thanks to this father-in-law
good stuff this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney and we are taking your calls
give us a call triple eight eight two
five
825-5225 dennis joins us in wichita
dennis welcome to the ramsay show
thank you appreciate it how can we help
today
i have a uh well actually my daughter
has a situation she's a 17 years old
her mom got her a checking account when
she was 16 and she's been working and
putting money away
and being very responsible
well a couple days ago
she got a message on instagram from
somebody she did not know
uh
saying that they enjoyed some of her
pictures and they wanted to use her
pictures and they would pay her for it
well what they ended up doing was they
sent her a check via email
said okay
for three thousand dollars we're going
to pay you for
the pictures
you keep 500 and send us back that money
when you deposit it the the 2500
ruselli so she did that i know
i would have saw it instantly but i told
her but
things happened well anyway she didn't
think anything of it she went ahead and
as soon as soon as the account said that
that money was there she sent it through
zelly to this individual
and then they tried it again
for another twenty five hundred dollars
and then my ex-wife got a uh
email or i'm sorry a text message saying
that the account was overdrawn and
there's suspicious activity on it
and so they went in they filed a police
report with their local police they sent
it over to their the bank's asset
protection
so my question is basically this
um they're saying that they got the
second one stopped but the first one she
may be on the hook for three thousand
dollars
which i i mean i kind of agree with but
i kind of don't agree because i thought
there should be some better protection
on uh a checking account for a minor and
that's what it was
so what kind of
what do we do my my thought was just let
them sue her for the money get in front
of this way she gets in front of a judge
they can you know at least talk to a
impartial person the judge and say hey
this was scammed we shouldn't be owed
this they didn't do anything to protect
this
this account from fraudulent activities
and fraudulent checks because
it's definitely fraudulent
yeah so we're just kind of what do we do
how honest can i be with you
perfectly go ahead all right um
i don't know what's
uh state you're in kansas there um every
state's different
but if i'm a judge and you bring this to
me
i'm gonna turn around and say where were
the parents of this minor
because they're ultimately in charge
when you open an account like that and
so yes a bank should have they're going
to open up an account for minors there
should be protections and all that but
any to anything legally always rolls
downhill to the parent not always but
almost always rolls downhill to the
parents
or uphill to the parents
and so you can do that
i think this is an extraordinary
expensive
pull your hair out frustrating but
extraordinary
gift for your daughter if y'all frame
this right if you frame it as making
this the bank's fault then you're
teaching your daughter that if we make a
big mistake can we screw up even we're
trying to do right we thought we'd get
us
then there's always somebody else to
blame if you teach your daughter um man
we messed up you messed up big i'll
split this with you or you can work it
off in this way it's going to be very
expensive thing to learn
my promise is this never happens again
um i just was dealing with somebody
who's a friend of mine who's got a
college age kids um was caught up in a
sexting thing in a very similar scam via
instagram
and it was a mess caused a lot of
heartache and a lot of police reports on
here's what i can promise you that will
never happen again
right and
i'm more interested in setting up a 17
year old with a 3 000 lesson usually
it's a car wreck or something like that
that you can learn a lesson like this
set it up a lesson like this and this
never happens again then i am about well
they should have had man i i personally
am not going to go down that road and if
i'm a judge i'm going to look at you dad
or look at your ex-wife and say where
were parents when this stuff was going
on
um that's my that's my take on it george
i thought yeah i just keep thinking man
this could be a
expensive road to go down just fighting
this thing in court when we get we even
know who this guy is and so as far as
recourse goes sure you can report it to
zell you can you know go after your bank
and say hey this was fraud this is
legitimate fraud but at the end of the
day there's a level of stupid tax here
where we have to go okay red flag number
four thousand if they send me three
thousand but i'm only getting 500 this
is a scam when they overpay
and let me tell you uh i fell for this
john when i was younger i shipped a pair
of shoes on craigslist to nigeria
because he said it was first cousin and
i got a paypal email he paid extra for
the shipping and i thought wow this
guy's legit he really just wanted to
send these to his cousin it was a fake
email and it took a lot of sleuthing to
even figure out it was a fake email but
i should have checked my bank account
and said is this money actually there is
this actually in my paypal account and
so there's a lot of things we do as
teenagers and there's two people getting
scammed these days older folks and young
folks the people in the middle hopefully
know better but
especially young people they can be
susceptible because they're they're used
to venmo and zell this is in their world
but unless they're mailing me a check
and i go to the bank and cash that check
it's fraud i know i sound like a gong
george and hey dennis i appreciate your
vulnerability and i appreciate you
calling and asking i and i know things
are challenging because you're parenting
in two different households here this
young lady
if you were gonna hand a child a
smartphone
and you're gonna give them open access
to the internet to all social media and
let's let them go because they're just
kids and they're
please do your due diligence and look at
what is happening to our young people
who are involved in this
just having free reign of the internet
free reign of these social media apps
free reign of
this is the best case scenario quite
honestly yeah that someone she got lost
she lost three thousand bucks and
learned a hard lesson
um the number of people over my years
working at colleges that were caught up
with pictures compromising pictures of
them that are out they could never get
back um that people were taking their
text message i mean all kinds of stuff
parents
you have to be
in your kids business especially when
they're minors
well i don't want to be private they're
15 they're 17 they're 14 they're 13. get
in their business get in their business
we don't let them buy beer we don't let
them buy smokes we don't let them go to
war we don't let them buy guns because
we know that their brains aren't fully
formed yet we hand them the internet and
say make good choices right and there's
entire industries that are built on
on preying on these young folks parents
get involved have that conversation and
say here's the ground rules also if
anyone asks you for money wants to give
you money this is a conversation that
goes straight to the parents and we talk
about or be a luddite and just
don't give your kid access to the
internet
john no one's ever wanted to buy my
photos that i post on instagram
so and i'm gonna be i'm a big deal john
so i don't know what what she got on
there no one's ever
i'm not gonna oh you know what someone
reached out and said they'd like to pay
for my pictures of my feet
and that's what i thought i'm gonna hard
nope on that i'm not gonna be friends i
hope that was rhetorical like you're
talking about someone else
no
dear lord
okay
and if they're reaching out to oh god
help us parents social get involved in
your kids lives
get involved in your kids lives you're
not being a helicopter parent you are
being wise
be a caring parent yeah well this is not
encroaching on their privacy this is
helping them avoid some huge mistakes a
three thousand dollars got two little
dogs do they have their own account uh
you know if they could open a bank
account john i would i would know about
your instagram account oh yeah one of
them's got one we don't post though come
on we're better than that we gave up on
it did you yeah like just it's just you
and me and a couple of people
are you being honest you give up on it
100 you can go check it i'm proud of you
george thank you i know it's hard social
media is hard enough on your own let
alone posting for an animal that can't
post for itself but some good lessons
here john social media i think this is
one of these things this this generation
has to grapple with and go what's the
healthy way to use this yeah absolutely
because it's going to happen more and
more and more and more and more and more
and more yeah so parents need to have
these conversations set some ground
rules set some boundaries get so that we
don't end up in a situation like this
yeah it's sad i hate that for you
brother i hate that dennis i hate that i
hate that i hate that man blood just for
your little girl too i hope she gets the
money back somehow it'd be great but
i've heard with these zelle scams it can
be really difficult to get your money
back
not a lot of recourse on this but she
gets it back call us up let us know
we'll cheer on with you man that puts
this hour of the ramsay show in the
books our thanks to james childs our
producer kelly daniel associate producer
and phone screener and ben hill on the
board keeping the show afloat appreciate
you guys and i appreciate you america
thanks for listening in we'll be back
with you before you know it
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
ramsey personality george campbell
joined today by dr john deloney and we
are excited to take your calls
about life money relationships mental
health boundaries
getting scammed on instagram
your emergency fund maybe an inheritance
you name it we'll talk about it open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five
joshua kicks off this hour in dallas
texas joshua welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys pleasure to be on there today
what's up man
hey i have a question i make about 48
000 a year
i have a fully
funded emergency fund about four to five
months
is what i have in my checking account in
my savings i have about twenty five
thousand dollars
that i don't know what to do with
and the problem to have
that may be one of the better problems
we deal with today josh well done
well i appreciate that um
glory to god by the way for that um but
uh i i'm wondering if i should give that
25 000
to my edward jones guy and we could put
it in my hot roth or my
or 403 b or whatever i don't know the
right terms for that
or if i should put it toward my mortgage
and pay down my mortgage
well you're following the steps so far
and so you are at baby step four five
six you do you have any kids
i have three daughters and one boy on
the way okay congratulations that's
awesome man
you're crushing it thank you so are you
currently investing 15 or is this kind
of a new uh step for you
i am almost i can get to 15 i haven't
started that yet i just got
a raise at my job um so i hadn't
adjusted uh my giving to my in here or
my uh retirement yet okay well let's
first start on that 15 towards
retirement and then once we get that
plate spinning you're consistently
investing that 15 every single paycheck
then we're gonna move on to step five
we're gonna throw a little bit of money
for each of those kids in a college fund
that could be a 529 or an esa
and you should be able you could do both
i'd probably start with the esa right
now um you could throw you know up to
the max about two grand
for the year for each of those kids that
could be cool
and then beyond that we're paying off
the house early and so this money has
has now been allocated it has a job and
it was so fun to be holding on to it
until george just took it all away from
you i won the lottery
yep so that i would do it in that order
and so that might not mean you make a
big lump sum for investing or for the
kids college fund but i want you to be
able to have that margin consistently in
your budget in four or five to be doing
that every month and then beyond that
every extra dollar that's coming in
beyond your you know normal lifestyle
stuff which you guys can you can enjoy
life that's what we want for you in baby
steps four through seven
and so you can enjoy some of it i would
give some of it and i would save some of
it
josh what do you do for a living
i am the children's pastor children's
pastor
um
how honest can i be with you
go for it go for it uh 48 000 bucks a
year raising four kids in dallas seems
like a tough slog
well i'm outside of dallas um
uh yeah we're making it the lord has uh
he's blessed me with uh good vehicles
okay uh my house is is a little on the
small side
um
we're a little crammed in there but um
the area we live in if we wanted to
upgrade especially right now it's just
um it's just out of the question okay
um with the housing market and so
uh you know god has has
really really uh blessed me
and um uh 48 uh we make it every single
month good and uh we have we're in the
black every month excellent every year
we've seen um
uh growth in in our finances and all i
can say is you know praise god for that
but this this 25 000 is
a culmination of a couple tax
refunds
saving and
uh i i loaned out some money and that's
going to get paid back and and
my church mispaid me uh a couple times
uh they they didn't uh pay me the full
amount sure they missed you joshua
sure they did
they accidentally didn't pay my my
health insurance for the whole year
um so i got a big check back for that
that's a big whoopsie
hey so i i appreciate um your deference
to god's favor and
but i want you to also um you and your
wife i want to personally celebrate you
both of you for your stewardship and
your
just
incredible discipline with your money
a couple of tax returns that means
you've been sitting on this money for a
long time in a tight tight budget
and so good for you for
making every penny count and for eking
it out and being able to survive a year
when your employer
quote unquote forgot to pay you the
health classes benefits the old classic
forgot to pay the health insurance thing
yeah but good for you brother yeah
that's a it's a great question though a
lot of people have money sitting around
and they know it could be doing better
in the market right we always hear that
why i can make 10 12 in the market john
why would i use it as an emergency fund
yep why would i use it to fund my kids
college and it's funny as as i've talked
to people who follow the steps and the
people who don't the people who follow
the steps have a lot less anxiety in
their life because it's just it
simplifies everything you just go i know
exactly where this money's going i'm
going to invest it i'm going to save for
my kids college i'm going to pay off the
house diligently instead of throw it on
the market hope for the best and watch
my phone 24 7. as it as it rockets up
and down which we've been seeing the
past few weeks haven't we
well if i pay attention to the stock
market yes i do walk by the tvs and see
the up arrows and down arrows and yeah
see the people pulling their hair out
and whatnot and all the crypto bros
going nuts as it crashes to half of what
it was can we just say that about six
months ago i told you that was gonna
happen
you did john you prophesied it i don't
think i prophesied i just
saw krypto as a deflation hedge and when
inflation was going up anyway that's a
whole other conversation all right we'll
save that but that's a great question
very good question from joshua there
about savings accounts so if you have
extra money here's the simplest way if
you're listening right now and you've
got that situation filter it through the
baby steps where are you at if you're at
baby step three well you might be able
to fully fund that emergency fund if
you're at four five six well now you've
got some margin
we can start investing maybe you can
fill up that roth ira for the year maybe
you can
throw a huge chunk in a 529 to set your
kids up for success or you've got that
mortgage and you're sick of paying the
lender every single day that's me man i
just want to get rid of that mortgage
like that thing this is your year john i
believe in you i well i don't know we'll
see i'm sure i'm cheerleading you on but
yeah that you know the freedom that
comes with not owning anybody anything
on your house even if it's just like
joshua says a small cramped house
getting that mortgage knocked out man oh
man oh man it's so great i keep waiting
for the email that's like hey your
mortgage is due and it never comes john
i know and i can't say i miss it and
that paycheck that just deposited today
it's all yours now it's all mine and it
goes mostly to my dogs
that's that you can call my show for
that yep that's a whole another problem
john i need a whole coaching session
there well hey folks
open phones aaa 825-5225
give us a call we will talk about
whatever is on your mind i'm george
campbell joined today by dr john delony
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
so
[Music]
i'm george campbell joined today by dr
john dolone this is the ramsey show give
us a call triple eight eight two five
five two two five
sam joins us in portland oregon sam
welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks for having me sure how can we
help
yeah so my wife and i were just
introduced to total money makeover a
little over a month ago and finished
reading the book
finished step number one and they're
starting baby step number two awesome um
a couple or two and a half years ago or
so we made the wise decision of leasing
a ford explorer
and in september that police is coming
up to an end
i am seeking just your guys's opinion or
this recommendation on on what we should
do
when that lease comes to an end
you know how should we approach that
obviously i think either purchasing it
or returning the leased vehicle
is probably preferred but how can my
wife and i prepare
for that you know upcoming you know
expense or upcoming event
taking into consideration
the baby stuff that we're on right now
is the uh george can walk you through
this i just have a quick question does
the
is the payoff amount baked into your
lease agreement
does it have a payoff amount if we go
you've already contractually agreed
if we go over in miles
are you talking about the earth the buy
out john yes here's why i'm asking
is there like
two years ago the prices of an explorer
were not with a two-year-old explorer
would not be what it is right now is
there a chance that this you're making a
you know doing something goofy getting a
car released two years ago
can turn around and you can buy a a
two-year-old explorer for way less than
if you went and bought a two-year-old
explorer from off a car lot somewhere
yeah that makes sense what's your
[ __ ] is it baked in there do you know
or is there a market value paid off okay
what's your income what's the household
income here
yeah house cold incomes right around
180. awesome a year that's good news
what's the car worth today
um
the um
the purchase auction price is right
around 30 000. okay so that's what you
would owe in september
if you wanted to keep the car to
purchase it what's that car worth
i don't know probably i'll need a kelly
blue book it but
it has gotten in like a it got side
swiped um so there's some repairs that
need to be done to it um
either prior to that or for a walk away
um
but you're gonna have to do those
repairs anyway
right if you hand them the keys to that
thing you're gonna have to make those
repairs anyway right
exactly what what other debt do you have
what's the total and what's it made up
of
yeah um
we have a total of
a hundred thousand
um most of it is in student loans um 84
000 is in student loans
we have another car that we own um that
has 7 000
left on it
we have roughly eleven thousand dollars
in credit card and a little over 500 in
medical bills
all right
well i'm going to give you some some
good news and the bad news the good news
is you have a fantastic income and
you're going to be able to be able to
save up and pay cash for a used car by
september
the bad news is i think this car is
going away because we have a pile of
debt to clean up right now and we're
just not at a place to own a car that's
worth this much
but with your income
you get 100k in debt i want you to
filter this through the debt snowball
once you have that amount saved which
how quickly could you save up for a used
car let's say five six seven eight
thousand dollars
and make 180 000 a year
it takes you three months to get a
couple grand
i mean maybe probably sooner and we have
three kids as well um where daycare
costs come in there you go okay
each week so that's here i think you
could clean up the credit cards and that
car loan for 7k before this lease even
comes to an end
yeah
where that puts you is you've got just
the student loans you're down to 84 000
in debt making 180k
and that's it and we're going to plow
through that debt as quickly as possible
my guess is that takes you a year
could you do that 18 months
to get to get through all of that to get
through the student loan debt
yeah i mean that's the plan um
like i said we're fresh on this and
we're kind of attacking this head on um
trying to get good at budgeting
um
but you know i i think it's totally
totally feasible you use the every
dollar app
uh we we don't have that i've just been
writing it down oh that's cool so hey so
stay on the line we're gonna give you a
copy of
uh i mean we're gonna give you a year
subscription to our flagship product
ramsey plus and it's got all the videos
from financial peace university in it um
it's got lots of different um different
there's a lot of content in there to
keep you on your journey over the next
you know two two and a half years as you
pay the stuff off but it also has um a
premium subscription for a year to the
every dollar app that's going to connect
you and your wife y'all are going to be
able to track expenses work together on
this deal and get this stuff knocked out
for you and your three little kids is
that cool
awesome i appreciate that thank you so
much you got it man hang on the line
here kelly will hook you up thanks for
the question sam chris joins us in miami
florida chris welcome to the ramsay show
hey good afternoon guys how are you
great how can we help
so i
i
last year i paid off my mortgage pretty
much all my debt and yes way to go it's
awesome
yeah feels good it definitely feels good
i i i
was listening earlier i feel the same
way i'm kind of waiting for them to send
the bill but it never comes so i love it
um
my question is this i'm putting away for
the kids i have two kids five and seven
i'm putting away for the kids school for
the future my wife and i are
contributing 15 percent
into retirement
um but and i have i mean i think at this
point i have like 12 months worth of uh
of expenses saved up um
so i'm wondering what the next step is
you know i i do give to the local church
faithfully the church that we go to
we're part of
um so and we are enjoying some of it
um but as far as
the rest of it i mean i've got a
significant amount of money or what i
think is significant amounts just kind
of sitting there in the savings account
fix
not really generating all that much and
so
i just at this point i'm kind of like
now what sure sort of the honeymoon the
honeymoon is over and that's like now
what and you guys you guys are spending
and having a good time right you're not
just hoarding this money and living a
miserable life
no we're definitely not miserable um
definitely
no i mean my life's better than yours
george they're just saying this nicely
but there's two camps better than you
george some people are have a real hard
time enjoying themselves once they hit
step seven and i just want to make sure
that that's not an issue for you guys
that you're not you know hanging on with
a closed fist going we can't go on
vacation it'll never be enough and so if
you're at that point there's a few
things you can do obviously you know
you're already giving and you're
spending and so your question is how do
i make this money work for me on the
savings side on the investing side
right
if i'm you i'm gonna park this in index
funds for now until we have a plan for
it
and that's what dave does when he wants
to buy real estate with cash he just
parks in index funds lets it grow and
when the time comes he's got enough
money to buy something he'll pull it out
and buy something and so i would just
put it in one of those taxable
investments and index funds you can also
throw in some mutual funds and work with
our smartvestor pros on that but that's
what i'm doing until i know what that
next thing is and you have a wife
yeah yeah yeah she yeah she's a teacher
i'm a
gpa and
we both work i'd sit down go to a nice
dinner and start dreaming about what do
we want to do do we want to get into
real estate investing do we want to do
something outrageous do we want to sock
this away for college or for vacations
what do we want to do with this money
that would be just totally outrageous
because we lived like no one else and
now we get to live like no one else yeah
i can tell you she wants to do real
estate and then her and i kind of are on
the same page you got your answer chris
that's your next one i have enough to
buy it yeah we just don't have enough
right now to buy a cat yeah i just keep
saving you know that you know the drill
you gotta save up some money do it with
cash and let that be your next goal we
are such driven people as humans john at
least the good ones there's always
there's always a next goal we gotta
dangle to keep us motivated along the
journey and so that's not a bad thing uh
and you you told me your wife wants to
get into real estate let's have some fun
with real estate and we're going to do
it with cash which means there's going
to be no risk no stress other than being
a landlord which comes with its own
profits
hey it changes the game when you don't
have a mortgage on it that's a total
game changer thanks for the call man
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
every january we get hundreds of calls
from people who are ready to start fresh
and finally take control of their money
but without a plan most of them never
make progress and just give up maybe
you've been there too but 2022 can be
different this year you can win with
money by following a plan that's worked
for millions including myself that plan
is financial peace university you'll
learn step by step how to save money pay
off debt fast build wealth and give
generously you can go through the class
with other people or watch it online at
home either way fpu is available only
with a ramsay plus membership this year
you can take control of your money for
good start fpu for free by visiting
ramseysolutions.com
fpu that's ramsey solutions.com
fpu
open phones this hour i'm george
campbell joined today by dr john delony
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five elizabeth joins
us in norfolk virginia
elizabeth welcome to the show how can we
help
hello it's so exciting to talk to you
we're excited to talk to you what's
going on in your world
so i just need some advice my husband
and i are on babysit four and five we're
hoping to build a home
this coming fall so that's why we're not
on six we currently rent right now okay
um but i've had
some controversy
in my current employer with my current
employer
and it's been a difficult last four
months
a little bit of just burnout on my side
and moving towards just i don't want to
say toxic but it's just been an
uncomfortable working environment so
what's this called also
so um i'm currently an assistant manager
um i work in health care
and it's just
i'm sorry i was just making an office
reference assistant to the regional
manager that's all
oh
so um yeah so i'm in healthcare i'm an
assistant manager and healthcare is a
very difficult climate right now and my
boss and i aren't necessarily seeing eye
to eye
we've had some conversations
and it's moved forward
and it's just become a question of my
work ethic
and whether i'm pulling enough hours
whether i'm meeting the job requirements
or not i've tried to receive it very
positively so that i can move forward
and be what my team needs me to be
in my work environment but then it's
also affecting just how much i'm at home
which is very difficult because i have
three young children and i'm trying to
balance being everywhere i need to be
right now yeah um let's back out 30 000
foot feet for a second
how are you you mentioned burnout you
mentioned you got three little ones you
mentioned be in a bunch of different
places how are you in this season
i'm
very burned out
you're cooked i've been in i've been
i've been a nurse for 15 years okay in
emergency department so i'm cooked
that's right um
you're cooked
if we're honest and i i've
got a i've spent years working with
folks in your world
you're cooked before kovid and this is
like nothing else right afterwards right
the last two years have been
insanity for for nursing professionals
so
is the so let's go back into the
hospital now is the criticism you're
receiving fair and there's a point to
why i'm asking you this stuff
no
no
okay
sometimes not sometimes always when i'm
get chaotic when i get exhausted when i
am dealing with kid stuff and i don't
gotta run over here my wife needs me to
and then i just happens to be the day
that one of the folks that i work with
here says you know what you need to
really step up
they're often right and as frustrating
or as angry as that makes me when they
when they say something when james is
like hey delaney you to be on time man
he's right you know what i mean
but you're saying your boss is not right
and in fact your your boss is
contributing to
this feeling not calling out things that
are going to help things
correct
okay so do you still want to be a nurse
um some days
not every day
yeah
is that new or is that long long
standing
that's long standing okay okay
so back to your original question how
close are you to the end here
well
we're hoping to build in the fall
so
our income is a huge driver to this
question because we've made more than
we've ever made before our income is
about 175 a year 175 000 a year
so we're really
saving a lot because we have this end
goal of finally building the home that
we want which would require us
moving
and
new jobs
new schools everything elizabeth if you
build this house
and it requires you to die every day to
do it will it be worth it
i hope so
i'm telling you right now it will not be
okay one of the hardest things about
reaching goals is that we go with us
wherever you end up you will be there
and if you are fried and cooked and
exhausted then you're gonna be fried and
cooked and exhausted in a brand new
fancy house with new schools you're just
gonna be more stressed because you had
to move and change schools with three
little ones
yes i would much rather you see you
square your heart and your mind and your
professional life up
and make it more in line with the
reality that three kids is thrown into
your life whatever your husband and your
relationship looks like i'd much rather
you line those things up and then say
what do i want to do what do we want to
do
and then say how do we fit our dream
goals which is building a house buying a
boat whatever moving to paris whatever
that is
can we do that in
in in reality
do you hear do you hear like just listen
back to what you've told us you're
you're basically sacrificing yourself
for this other dream over here
yeah
have you looked at other other jobs
do you know that this is the only place
that you can work that'll pay you this
much
no i i haven't
i think that's a good first step
because i think in your head you're
going well if i go to another job i'm
not going to make as much why are you
scared to
because this is i've done this for so
long i know what i'm doing yeah the
devil you know if i step out of my i
step out of my comfort zone
i have to learn something else
yeah but you're capable of that you're
amazing
you can absolutely learn something new
you can start somewhere fresh you're
going to move somewhere fresh anyways
right you just told us that
that's true so i would start looking and
if it's in the new area that you guys
want to live that's not a bad thing
either
and you can rent for there for a little
while maybe a six month lease until you
can build this dream home but there's
really nothing driving the urgency of
this home other than we want to right
but there's something driving the
urgency of the other side of this
equation which is you cannot keep going
like you're going
it's exhausting it is would you take a
10 000
pay cut per year
if it meant you weren't in a toxic
environment and it slowed down this home
process by a month or two would you do
it
yes
i think we have our answer i think
you've got to do some research and not
be afraid of the unknown because you're
about to step into it anyways if you're
going to move to a new town with new
jobs and new house and all of that stuff
so you can do hard things elizabeth can
i tell you uh where i would start with
this elizabeth if i'm you because i know
it feels overwhelming
have you sat down with your husband and
told him i'm not okay
we talked about it okay
but i told him i could push through if i
needed to okay
i would love to see you and take him to
dinner
and
you all sit down and have a honest
conversation because i think you've
hinted at it hoping he would pick up on
it and pull the plug on this deal
or
hint at it and say well i can you know
what i'm saying and i think it's time
that you are able to lay all the cards
on the table and say
we got three kids we've got this we've
got that we've got that you and i
our relationship has changed not for
better or worse it's just different now
we got three kids we're both working
full time things are bananas and
i can't continue
at this trajectory whether that means
i'm getting out of nursing whether that
means
i want to stay at home with the kids
whether that means i got to just change
hospitals because i can't work with a
supervisor anymore i got to change
whatever that means
i think we need to sit down on the table
with your number one fan your chief
partner in life and say
[Music]
i'm out i can't go anymore like this and
i don't know what this means yet and i
promise that i'm going to get to the
bottom of it
and then let's build something new
together man i feel for the healthcare
workers john it's i think everyone is
experiencing some level of what she's
experiencing it's unbelievable it's hard
been through toxic long hours
no end in sight i feel for you elizabeth
good luck on your journey this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsay personality host
of the fine friend and entree leadership
podcast joined today by dr john delony
host of the dr john deloney show you can
find this show and all the shows i
mentioned on the ramsey network or
wherever you listen to podcasts mary
joins us in st louis mary welcome to the
ramsay show
yes i have been trying
to get my financial advisor to convert
some of our ira into a roth
i've been trying for about three years
he has
one excuse after another i've told him
the taxes are low now i would rather
pull it out put it in or off pay the
taxes then have wait until the taxes
increase
but he says no that's not a good idea
mary are you married to this man
no then why haven't you fired him yet
oh i'm thinking about it
i have been it's been three years
yes
wow
well okay let me i just want to hear
some of the excuses what is he saying
why doesn't he want to do this
uh he has said it's too late i should
have done it years ago
he is saying if there's any money left
over
and my daughter inherits it let her pay
the higher taxes things like that
but he doesn't get to tell you what you
do with your money
that's the hallmark of a bad financial
advisor yeah this guy's the worst
even if he's right the way he's doing it
is just
bonkers
yeah fire him today and smile when you
do it
is converting part of the money into a
roth a bad idea
if you have the cash on hand it's not
can you afford to pay the taxes on it
um i think so how much money do you have
in the ira that he's handling sure 2-1
how much 2.1 million
yes
wow
way to go mary
and so what's your what is your
reasoning for wanting to convert it
taxes
i don't want to pay higher taxes
he is saying no don't convert it
whoever inherits it can pay the higher
taxes
so how old are you 72 and my husband's
73. okay
so you're going to pay taxes either way
you're going to pay taxes on it right
now because because it's traditional so
if you pulled out the 2 million you're
going to pay that as you know your
income tax of whatever you pull out when
you convert it pull out about 80 a year
80 a year okay and you're saying i don't
want to pay the taxes on the 80 a year
no i don't mind doing that um
in fact i have asked him we get the
rmdis
i have asked him if i could have that
divided up
by 12 and get that much more money every
month the required minimum distribution
yes yes and he says no i can't
i'm just you know i'm trying to see an
angle where maybe he's got some
reasoning behind this and maybe there is
but either way i'm getting a second
opinion so i want you to connect with
one of our smartvestor pros and just run
these numbers by them and say hey here's
what he's saying
here's what i want to do can you tell me
if he's is there a reasoning behind this
that you can help me understand because
our smart investor pros have the heart
of a teacher so they want to teach you
why they're recommending to do what they
say to do and so i would
change
i'm sorry i was going to say if i change
is that a
a
consuming thing that it's going to take
forever no no i did it recently
and i got connected with smart investor
pro and i had accounts scattered all
across
four or five jobs that i've had over the
last 20 years
and i
i mean i just had to sit on the phone
and they transferred it over it was a
very very simple process you're bringing
over a couple of million dollars in a
portfolio
the smart investor pro who takes you on
who partners with you for the rest of
your financial journey and then is going
to help you set this up for your kids to
be successful
they will bend over backwards to help
you because you're a even if i'm a
little client i got 2.1 million dollars
that i'm bringing over and they were
extraordinary in helping me walk through
the process it's in their best interest
to make this process the transfer as
simple as possible and okay but i have
one i'm sorry go ahead no that so yeah
don't don't worry about it's not a
complicated thing you have to sign a
paper and be on the phone when they do
some transfers but it's not it's not a
it's not what it's not like months and
months and weeping and hugging and all
this kind of stuff it's just gonna be
what it is okay the reason i hesitate to
uh get a different advisor is
this one picks the stocks by themselves
we have nothing to do with that
and he's been good we started off with i
think it was one two
and now it's been 10 years and we're at
2-1
dummy who's good at done a good job with
that well if you look over the last 10
years the market has been bonkers too
and so if the if the bullseye on the
dartboard is
you know 15 feet by 15 feet we all look
pretty good throwing darts right
okay
um so i i also here's the thing if he's
got a great performance great i still
think character counts and i think the
way he treats you counts
and so if he has a and i'm going to be
honest with you i'm not smart enough
this is george and dave's territory to
get into the conversion of roths and
time and how old you are and all that
i'm more concerned that he hasn't sat
down and taught you
here's why you don't want to do that
here's the mathematical reason why this
is not a good idea
and when you say i would rather eat the
taxes than cause my children to have to
pay taxes in the future and he says
give him your kids
i don't like the spirit of that yeah and
so this whole exchange needs to you need
to know why he's picking the stocks or
the the portfolio that he's picking in
fact the smartvestor pro started to tell
me and i said hey i don't honestly i
don't care i want it to match your
family's portfolio if it's good enough
for you it'll be good enough for my
family and he said
with all due respect i'm going to teach
you this and so i had to listen and say
here's why i'm doing this whatever so
i want you to
walk alongside whoever is is
pushing your financial future ahead of
you the reason i don't like this is you
get a couple of million dollars
and a lot of these investment folks out
there are unscrupulous they're gonna
they're gonna buy the products that make
them the most commissions
not a smart investor pro so make sure
you connect with somebody today yeah
jump on ramseysolutions.com and click on
trusted pros mary and you connect with
one in the st louis area over there
thanks for the question grayson joins us
in atlanta georgia grayson welcome to
the show
hi thank you sure how can we help
so i'm 21 years old i make sixty
thousand a year before taxes i live at
home with my parents have zero monthly
expenses what should i do with my money
how much do you have as far as savings
um right now i'm at about five grand
okay i just graduated college in
december awesome
good for you man what are you doing for
work
i have an accounting job for an hr
company nice and you graduated debt-free
can i ask how you did that
um i have about 10 000 in college loans
but uh my parents hold on for most of it
you just told me you're dead free
uh well other than that well you know
other than that lied to me on national
radio station
other than my face grayson come on
grayson we're paying off the student
loan you're saying mom and dad are
paying it off right now
uh they paid for
um for most of it yeah dude you're a big
point now it may be time to fly the coop
and pay off these loans yourself because
guess what for the rest of your life you
have to pay your own bills yes pay them
back off pay them off man
all right so answer this question about
the right so to answer the question you
make 60k i'd get a fully funded
emergency fund and i'd find somewhere to
live and start my life as an as an adult
you graduate you get a big boy job
what's the reasoning for staying with
the parents right now
um i'd rather not have to pay rent
somewhere if i don't have to
absolutely i could totally get that but
part of the adult experience in doing
the baby steps is
saving up for a down payment on a house
and investing 15 of your income and i
love the fact you're living your parents
and you have no expenses but
you're an adult
you've graduated so if i'm you i'm going
to go find a place to rent you make
great money for a 21 year old way more
than i did at 21 and so i would use that
money very wisely i'd get out of this
student loan debt and i'd stay out of
debt for the rest of my life i'd get
that fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months i'd start investing
15 into retirement which you're 21 you
will be a multi-millionaire if you just
invest consistently that 15 over time
and start to save up for a down payment
on that house whatever that looks like
for you
you got this dude you're crushing it at
21. but let's not pretend on what debt
is and what it isn't and it's time to
start paying your own bills man i
appreciate the call
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books my thanks to my awesome
co-host dr john deloney all the folks in
the booth james kelly
ben you name it they're making it happen
appreciate you guys listening in america
we'll be back with you before you know
it until next time spend wisely save
intentionally and give generously
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit the theramsieshow.com and register
we would love for you to come to
nashville and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm your
host george campbell joined today by dr
john deloney open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you call us up we'll talk about
whatever is on your mind
michael kicks off this hour in houston
texas michael welcome to the ramsay show
[Music]
thank you how are you guys doing today
great how can we help
well um just just trying to
navigate a situation with work i um
i i had a someone from my personal
network approached me with an
opportunity where
i was offered a consulting gig for a
a startup company mid-sized company
and i'm just concerned it might compete
with with my current work i'm currently
a valuation analyst
um
in in in finance so i just wanted to get
sort of a game plan on how to approach
the situation where to go from here
because it seems like a really great
opportunity i'd love to leap into and
you know would love to to take advantage
it's it's sort of where i would like to
be in my career at some point
uh working with small businesses and
sort of in the venture capital space so
i'd love to get y'all's advice do you
have a non-complete non-compete with
your current
employment employer
yes yes they do
do you have a good relationship with
your leader with a supervisor
um
not
i mean not
you know we don't go get beers after
work but i mean
if uh
if i approached him about it i mean i
think he you know it's a decent one not
a very let me let me tell you what
here's a live a live example here so
i've i've got a non-compete too so i
just can't quit and go work for somebody
else and whenever i
take speaking gig or go do some event
for somebody or something that funnels
through
ramsey's solutions and i get i get a
piece of that and uh dave and the team
get a piece of that
i was approached by a company to join
their board as they create products as
an expert on their board
and so that comes with equity stake in
the com it comes with several things
right and the first thing i did
was i just went and called my
boss
and said hey this isn't in our caught my
contract this in our agreement this is
something new the spirit of my contract
is they never would have known about me
had i not been
on this platform and so
it seems right that we work together on
this and at the same time it's not on my
contract so y'all can tell me right so
i'm telling you that to tell you a cool
opportunity came up that
never in a million years i thought was
going to happen in this particular space
and the first thing i did was i went and
sat down with my boss and said hey
here's what i agreed to here's what we
this falls into space between what our
agreement was how do we how do we figure
this out and so i'm i'm wondering why
you don't feel like you can go have that
conversation unless you're trying to do
something squirrely and
try to figure out a way that you can do
this off book and not tell anybody
absolutely yeah i know and that's that's
what i wanted to avoid because i mean
it's it's a situation where
i mean this certainly is where i'd like
to go in my career i'd like to go
towards it um but you know i i got to do
it in a way that you know is is legit
and you know i mean at some point you
know if i get any income off of this
that shows up on my
you know on my tax return and you know
any they can see that and and you know
at some point they'll start they would
ask it hey what's what's going on here
so
i your employer shouldn't see your tax
return
well just on like a background check for
um
you know for for because sometimes we
you know are offered to switch positions
and on that they do background checks
for
what's the nature of the non-compete
have you looked into it and actually you
know looked at the contract you signed
i have and and the nature of the
contract is such that um
it's there are two clauses in it number
one
specifically saying hey um
if you enter into any i mean it's a
direct if you enter in a direct
competition with you know with let's
call it the company the company being
valuation services financial services
investment banking so on so forth if you
enter into an agreement or or do
something that competes directly with
that that violates his contract
and then there's another clause in there
for solicitation of clients and
prospects
where they say hey if there's an
existing client that you work with
that's a no-go and if there's a prospect
that
you know you go forward and you present
them a formal business presentation you
give them a fee quote or services
within a certain period
of employment
12 months 18 months uh
what 18 months for current clients and
then 12 months for prospects
um so what i'm hearing is if you do this
you are in direct violation of the
non-compete that you signed right yeah
what's your question yeah and i haven't
entered in to be clear i haven't entered
into this this was just brought to me
yeah this is something that's incredibly
interesting and it's
it feels like a right step
um
i mean here's the thing there could be
severe consequences
we are not lawyers uh for good reason
but there could be injunctions there
could be monetary penalties i mean this
could be a nightmare for you and you
think this might be the dream step and
it could be in a different world but
right now man if you did this thing you
could be in a world of pain the other
the other
beneath the world of pain part
is how old are you man
uh 25. okay
if you are working in the financial
industry right now your friends are
already coming to you for consulting
work that means you're good
the rest of your life will be this
people coming to you out of a shadow
asking you to cut a corner or coming to
you just face to face they don't realize
what you're signed up for i want you to
be firm in who you are and if you put
your name on a contract you're gonna
you're gonna fulfill that contract if
you make an agreement even if you find
out later ah
you're gonna be a person of character
integrity
decide that at 25
and then live that on
and your life will simply be better you
might have to wait in a couple of years
before you get this opportunity or you
might have to say i can't do it this
time but next time remember whatever you
might have to do that but brother if you
make this concession now and you do this
through the back door and you figure out
a way to get away with it
in it 25 it's going to keep coming and
it's going to keep coming and the the
downfall will be big when it happens
okay
i would go straight in dude talk to my
boss and just say hey this was what was
offered to me or i guess one other thing
you could do
if you want to do it as a side hustle
tell your friend
um i'll do this but i can't charge i'm
going to do this like pro bono i'm going
to help out and maybe that won't violate
your your it probably still will but
maybe by not charging and there's no
money exchange and they're not
technically a customer you're just
helping out
that might be a way for you to get
experience to
thread the line here but yeah go to your
boss and talk to them i think integrity
is always the best move and if you want
to seek out you know a lawyer on your
end and just say hey i just want to make
sure i'm reading this clearly i think
you know the gray area but this it seems
like there's no way about this that you
can avoid it and here's the bigger
question if you can't trust your
supervisor
to have this conversation and they're
not going to go dude that's a great
opportunity that's awesome you can't do
it but i apprec if you don't have a
supervisor that you trust you start
looking for their job because this is
gonna be short term a relationship
anyway
good word this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so
[Music]
here at ramsey solutions we are on a
mission to transform so many lives that
disruption spreads like wildfire what
the heck does that mean well just
imagine a world where it's weird to have
a student loan instead of everyone
assuming that that's the only way to get
an education imagine a world where it's
normal to pay cash for your car imagine
a world where credit cards are the
cigarette of the financial industry now
imagine being part of the team that's
making all that a reality through the
work you do every single day at ramsey
solutions we have a thousand people
working together to create digital
products and services that will
transform people's lives we're out to
disrupt the toxic money culture that
exists in america today if that sounds
nice to you if it's exciting to you if
you want to join us on that crusade
we're currently on the hunt for
developers or if you're you're a ux
designer or seo and content marketing
specialist we'd love to talk with you as
well we've got lots of other options for
you over at ramseysolutions.com
careers you can check out all of the
available jobs by going to
ramseysolutions.com
careers
john joins us in san diego california
john welcome to the ramsay show
hey thanks you guys for having me today
honor to speak with you and your
listeners thank you how can we help
yeah so just a question for you guys my
fiance and i are getting married uh in
august cool and i've been drafting up uh
thank you guys yeah we've been drafting
up a kind of a plan to combine our
finances once you get married and
obviously we'll do our day-to-day
checking account but beyond that you
know i was curious what what you guys
teach i was looking for a video that
dave was talking about this and couldn't
find one
how many other bank accounts should
we have open or do you recommend that we
have open to just kind of manage our
financial goals and go up the baby steps
so i'm just curious to get your thoughts
first of all john you are a stud the
fact that you're trying to map out a
plan for this already
i mean i feel like this marriage is
already off
to a good start john well you know
nerds attracts i think we both are into
members in math and we're both very
excited to do this and you're both on
board with the ramsey plan
yes yes
they're going to be unstoppable all
right john so i'm going to tell you what
i did in my marriage okay
okay the first time
same marriage what i was going to say
clarify john clarify and then after we
were married for a while
i'll tell you what what happens now okay
when we first got married
let's be honest i was a genius and by
genius i mean i was an idiot
and i had an account for savings i went
to one bank then i went to another bank
for our checking account where our
paychecks were deposited i had another
bank for like a side hustle account i i
ended up with bank accounts everywhere
and i thought what i was doing was
making things very simple and cut and
dry i would always know where this was
and that was there
what i made was a
huge mess
a giant
idiotic mess
and so now
we have
one account
a one central account and in it we have
sub accounts there one might be a
savings account one as our emergency
fund one is a lagging fund because the
way we get paid here at remedy solutions
so i will
dump money into that one and hold it so
i can pay some might continue to pay my
house off and things like that but i
create we create sub accounts and then
if we want to have a sinking fund to
save up for a car we created another one
and dump money to that one so it all
stays in the same place we can see it
with the same account it goes on the
same every dollar app we don't have to
deal with 50 different banks that's my
recommendation yeah that's a good word
there and i'll tell you what i do john i
keep our emergency fund in a separate
online high yield savings account and
then we do all of our other banking with
a local brick and mortar uh here in town
and we have a checking account and then
we have our savings accounts like john
said you can have multiple we have one
for seeking funds we have one for
vacation we have one for the car upgrade
fund and that doesn't complicate things
but what it does when it's in one
account it helps you separate what's for
what right because you have one giant
savings account you go well how much is
this for the car and how much is this
for emergencies and what's for vacations
and so you can make as many as accounts
as you want but like john did don't over
complicate it
if you have 15 accounts it may get a
little hairy so i was go i would say
have as few as possible while still
accomplishing your goals
yeah because you know with all the
advent of online banking i mean there's
so many ways to check a million
different banking apps and she and i
have like several credit union accounts
that we've individually had open since
we're both in college obviously we'll
close those or add each other's names to
them but i like the idea of just
streamlining it so that it's all
in one place does this also go for like
obviously our roth ira is going to stay
independent well you know because it's
an individual retirement account um do
you guys recommend that when couples get
married if they have the exact same
financial advisor for both of those
accounts or you know she and i obviously
before we met had different um financial
advisors for those so
um what do you guys recommend for those
kinds of accounts
forever that will stay independently who
does better you'll have a death match
and you see which one you pick i'm just
kidding
yeah hey
keep just let this be as you all start
your marriage
let this let the word simple
distill every one of your decisions
what's the simplest way we can do this
right now
the world is selling us complexity the
world is selling us you need to be doing
this if you're not doing that you should
be doing that and why why oh you're just
in the world is telling us individualism
which is how dare you
communicate with somebody else about
their financial goals that's hers well
she's my wife i don't care that's her
goals your goals
simple simple
simple um yeah i recommend having the
same financial planner
i don't want to get different advice
than my wife's getting and we're gonna
we're both working together towards the
same financial goal and i want you in
the room at the same time talking to
that person right so you both have the
same language and understanding versus
well my financial advisor told me to do
this they told you you told me to do
that so i would keep it simple like
john's saying stick to that checking
account a savings account and if you
want to keep it separate because that
makes me not touch the cookie jar when
it's over here in this online account
yeah i like that and you sometimes will
get a higher interest right now i'm at
like one percent which is amazing in the
world of a savings account crushing the
game
but again it's not there to make you
money it's there to protect you thank
you so much for the question my man ryan
joins us in detroit michigan ryan
welcome to the show
uh thank you guys for taking my call um
i'm 18 years old about to graduate high
school not going to be going to college
and so i'm going to be going to work
right away and my plan is to invest 100
every week until i retire and my
question was
where is the best place to put that
money
great question and way to go man what
are you gonna be doing for work
i'm gonna be a stone mason
cool atta boy man that's incredible
that's so rough sound like a stone mason
uh thank you i don't even know what that
sounds like but if i had a voice
picture in my head of a stonemason it
would be yours ryan i sound like generic
brand pee wee herman exactly exactly
all right ryan so let's let's talk
through this what do you think you're
gonna be making as a stonemason
i'm gonna start out making about forty
thousand dollars a year boom with no
debt
nope so you don't have any payments in
the world no no credit cards no student
loans nothing
nope do you have an emergency fund of
three to six months
i do
man
this kid is crushing it okay so you're
wondering where to invest this money
i would start with a roth ira that's a
great option you can fully fund that you
said you're basically investing 5200 a
year
yep so at that point you wouldn't get uh
quite to fully funding that roth ira but
that's a great start
that's what i would do if i was in your
shoes and then i would look into what my
employer offers do you know if they have
any kind of retirement plans through
work
i'm not sure okay well for now as long
as you have earned income you can open
that roth ira and you can put fifty two
hundred dollars in there and as your we
we recommend investing fifteen percent
of your income so let's say you're
making forty thousand if you're doing
the math with me ten percent is four
thousand
five percent is going to be two thousand
so we want you to put six thousand away
so
you should have the margin to put a
little more than what you're telling me
right
yep okay so let's make it a goal this
year you're making 40 grand your first
year working let's put 6000 away and
fully fund that roth ira i think that's
an awesome awesome goal for someone
you're right ryan if you pull this off
you will be so far ahead so the fact
that you're even thinking about this is
incredible you're going to be so far
ahead of your peers
if you're if you start at 18 maxing out
of roth or putting six granted her off
and parents listening listen when you
when you tell your kid you have to go to
college because you'll never be
successful meet ryan he's 18. ryan has
no debt ryan makes 40 grand a year in an
awesome trade that helps his community
ryan rocks be like ryan he builds stones
and he sounds awesome too but your kid
with his philosophy degree who spent 200
grand to get it who can't find a job
yeah brag about that to your friends
call ryan he'll hire you love it ryan
thanks for the question man we are
cheering for you love this john 18 year
olds crushing the game asking us where
to invest
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney and we've got a special debt
free screen coming up sarah and tim join
us how you guys doing hey we're doing
great good you got quite the squad
supporting you now all your team members
around and here's why it's special sarah
is one of our amazing team members me
and john both have the pleasure of
working with her and we are so pumped to
have you guys
we're glad to be here it's been a long
journey so let's get into it how much
debt have you guys paid off we've paid
off a hundred and forty six thousand
seven hundred and twenty three dollars
that's amazing yeah how long did that
take yep that took us 19 months okay
now we don't ask team members incomes
because all of the team is standing
around and uh as much as i like being
awkward come on we're not gonna do that
to you but man you guys have hustled
that's incredible okay so what kind of
debt was this uh this was a 100 student
loan
oh he did the slight nod like he didn't
want to throw under the bus this was all
of your debt it was all mine what was
the student what was the master's degree
in um so it was actually two degrees mfa
uh you was mfa yeah i was an mfa in
directing for cinema and then there was
a ba in film studies okay so you you
are an a
to say world class is underselling
world-class editor
and you look at things cinematically in
a way um that
is just unique and extraordinary
could you still have that without a
hundred and fifty thousand dollar mfa
yeah that's the thing sarah who are you
trying to impress because come on man
i'm impressed that's right did you just
want to grow in this area yeah i mean
for me i knew that like with my
personality and just who i am in general
it was going to be a lot harder for me
to do this without degrees and i knew
that school was kind of the um path for
me versus other people um so that's why
i decided to go the school route wow
okay and tim what do you do for a living
i'm a video production manager awesome
so you guys are both in the video world
and sarah's been on the team now for
about three years does a lot of video
editing for all the personality shows
that you guys get to see and she is a
rock star so three years ago you started
here on the team but 19 months ago
something shifted here what happened
yeah so tim and i going into our
engagement in 2019 we'd already had all
these conversations about the debt that
i had um and what was pretty amazing is
that tim had about twenty thousand
dollars of debt himself and he paid all
that off before he even proposed
and so he came into this knowing that we
had a hundred and forty six thousand
dollars worth of debt that was all mine
um so when he proposed we immediately
started having conversations about
the debt and how we were going to get it
paid off so we went into the marriage
already with the plan
and so yeah we got married and then we
had our honeymoon and then as soon as we
got back from the honeymoon we started
having those conversations
and then we started
budgeting around march but then that's
also when covet happened so we decided
to just stockpile so from march to
november we just stockpiled everything
that we had and then in november of 2020
we made our first like huge payment
and from then it's just been a lot of
jobs and between us tim took on several
side jobs i took on several side jobs
and we just hustled and then we paid it
off thanksgiving day last year amazing
so tim what'd you think walking into
this marriage like woo i paid my debt
off and now i have a mountain of 150 000
here
yeah it was
i've never shied away from a challenge
so
i knew our entire dating life which was
a couple years that this was looming and
we didn't really know how much it was
growing over time um and it's like a
tumor man this is bad you just had it in
the closet like let's just not look yeah
you never know when you log in and you
see oh gosh this has grown it's doubled
since the last time i looked at it so
that was always a low level anxiety in
the back of our heads and then when we
got engaged we started to really you
know dig into those numbers and say hey
this is how long it's going to take this
is how much we're going to have to
sacrifice
but i was all for it it's been a great
you know team building exercise a
relationship building exercise and uh
you know ups and downs but we've got you
know come out the other side of it uh
stronger for it and so um
from the beginning i was kind of excited
to dig into all of it so can i ask you
both a personal question that i normally
don't ask um
walk through your thought process
because there's people out there that
bring more debt to a relationship than
somebody else
or there's somebody else who is
participating in a
we're on the same team we're moving
forward together but this isn't none of
this is my dad and i really want a new
car i want to go on this vacation but we
agreed to like walk through the guilt
versus the hey we're all in this
together we speak to that
yeah so this was really hard um the
guilt part of it for me it just never
went away really
i
felt so grateful that tim
wanted to marry me knowing that i had
all that debt
but this was very difficult for us i
think part of it was circumstantial you
know we're newlyweds covet happens and
then we're two completely different
people with two completely different
approaches to paying off debt and how to
do that um
yeah i don't really know else would say
other than it was really difficult we
had to have a lot of communication and
there were days where there were a lot
of arguments and there was a lot of
disagreement
but we just had to continuously keep
talking about it
and keep learning about how the other
person handles this and processes it and
yeah we just took it some days it was
just taking it one day at a time just to
figure it out
wow yeah and for me it was always
in the back of my head sadly uh you
never really shake it when you go oh
well i could go do this well no i can't
um
but you know listening to the ramsay
show and constantly hearing callers
fighting through that same thing
then i'd be able to tell myself you know
it's i or sorry it's we not i we're
french now
um you know constantly hearing that all
the times dave says it um it really just
just kept ringing in my mind and
here we are got us through to the end
wow so what were these side hustles you
guys were doing because you both work
full-time and you went we're gonna make
this thing happen way faster i don't
know about you tim i know sarah full
time for you means you're up here
until you're the last person out of the
building sometimes so what yeah what
were you doing on the side after that uh
it was pretty crazy my days for most of
the heart most part was coming in at
seven staying till four or five um then
immediately going home and working until
about ten o'clock that night sometimes
it was an additional six hours of work
um so for me i actually started doing
contract jobs and like editing wedding
videos and then i got hired by this
awesome youtuber uh early on in the year
and i was consistently employed by her
for two different youtube channels um
for all of last year and part of this
year as well wow you guys are amazing
we're so proud of you
yeah okay so how does it feel to be
debt-free it feels incredible it's it
opens up so many doors and we we were in
it for so long that
our world kind of just wrapped around it
and we we got used to telling ourselves
no and and now that we're on the other
side of it and we can start telling
ourselves yes
it it just changes everything wow and on
the screen there i saw a piece of paper
that said mac dreamy tell me about that
gross what is that so i had this weird
idea that i could get out of debt
without having to change anything i
don't know where that came from i should
have known better um but part of it was
for me just to be able to get through
and be disciplined was keeping our
dreams at the forefront um so he and i
when we first made our budget like right
after we got married we wrote down all
of our dreams and some of them were like
huge huge streams um and then eventually
i put them on a huge post-it note and it
sticks right on our front door so
sometimes like when it was really hard i
would see like tim standing in front of
the door looking at it and sometimes i
would be standing at the door just like
staring at it and just trying to remind
myself like this is a lot bigger than us
and this is what we want to achieve
together
so yeah we have a lot of big dreams on
there but it helped keep us going well
listen sometimes
shame
paralyzes us
and sometimes resentment paralyzes us
and i don't want any listener to miss
how heroic and brave you both were to on
those hard days to get back up and keep
moving or to not let your
keep and then together y'all create
y'all did something amazing y'all have
completely shifted the rest of y'all's
who's life because you did something
really hard for 19 months i'm so proud
of you man wow it's incredible how old
are you
i'm 33 i'm 32. and completely debt free
not a payment in the world we're so
proud of you guys well we've got a copy
of baby steps millionaires in case you
didn't have a bunch already
that's the next chapter for you guys we
also have a copy of the total money
makeover for you to pass on to someone
who maybe feels like their their
mountain is too big to climb and you can
say no i did it here's how you can do it
too
unbelievable i know i would ask you
about cheerleaders but they're all
around you so let's get to it all right
it's sarah and tim nashville tennessee
147 000 paid off in 19 months count it
down let's hear a debt-free scream
three two one
that was visceral
[Music]
[Applause]
oh and the crowd goes wild you're the
best oh my goodness rock stars we're so
proud of you guys
man this is why we do what we do john
transformation freedom options meaning
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day comes from
proverbs 15 22.
plans fail for lack of counsel but with
many advisors they succeed
ken blanchard says none of us is as
smart as all of us
blinds.coms 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or pick the
wrong color they'll remake your blinds
for free you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos they
run every single month you'll save even
more use the promo code ramsay to get
the best deal
today's question comes from adam in
arkansas i've been trying to get my wife
on board with the baby steps but have
not been successful we have a decent
income of 150k but are living paycheck
to paycheck where basically roommates
financially because over 90 percent of
my paycheck pays all the bills including
the mortgage her paycheck only pays her
credit cards which she continues to use
we made an agreement to ditch the credit
cards two months ago
but instead she opened several more
credit cards and maxed her current ones
using christmas as her excuse
she has done this every year and said
she really wanted to change when i ask
what is important to her and what does
she want in her future she tunes out and
i'm starting to believe this is
significantly more than a financial
issue and that it may have some mental
health components how can i navigate
this with her oh man
um
you said the top of this question this
is one i wish we could talk to adam in
person but we are basically roommates
financially
i would be willing to bet my truck's not
nice but i'd be willing to bet my whole
truck that you're more than just
roommates uh financially
my
guess here is y'all are separate on just
about everything
it might be a mental health issue i
i mean
i can't even comment on that here what i
can comment on is
just in your language
my bills my check pays this her check
pays that
tells me you guys aren't doing things
together and when you're not doing
things for any
intrinsic reason when you're not working
with somebody towards a thing then it's
easy to default to your whatever coping
behaviors you have
and
for some reason she blows the cards up
she might have a mental health disorder
um i wouldn't start there i would start
immediately before the day is over i
would call a marriage counselor and let
the marriage counselor know my marriage
is
headed towards a disaster
um and adam i i can't say this
clearly enough
um
your marriage is in major trouble like
red flashing neon on lights um saying
danger danger danger and you need to sit
down with a professional right now um
you got somebody who's not telling you
the truth you got somebody who doesn't
appear to control their behavior
my guess is this story is much more
complicated than this yeah this is the
the tip of the iceberg is the spending
problems but there's a lot of language
in here that makes me think there's a
lot of work to be done and i think this
this necessitates marriage counseling
sometimes i say hey just go through
financial peace university together but
this feels deeper and there's more
behavioral uh change and things that
need to come out so i would do both well
and let's say there is let's say that
somebody's married somebody with some
mental health challenges okay they're
struggling
um this is where you when things are
good and people are are taking care of
themselves in a way that they can sit
down and say here's let's make some
rational decisions here um
that's when you put a freeze on
somebody's credit
um you both agree to it right or i'll
put a freeze on my credit i'll be say
this in the first person and put a
freeze on my credit so i can't just go
apply for credit cards i'm going to
disconnect amazon prime i'm going to
give up my atm card and i'm just going
to have cash
i'm going to go to extremes to protect
my marriage and this the safety of our
family financially and to begin to get
better control of my behavior i got to
practice new behaviors and i may have to
go full extreme here to do that yeah
absolutely i would get in touch with a
marriage counselor today today and i
would if she doesn't agree to go to
financial peace university and just say
hey just watch these videos with me
engage in a conversation with me let me
know what you're thinking about this
stuff if she's not willing to do that i
mean there's not there's not much else
you can do to force someone to change
their behavior there's nothing you can
do to force them to change your behavior
they got to want to so she's got to turn
a corner here at some point man sorry to
hear that you're going through something
like that all right will joins us in
denver colorado will welcome to the
ramsay show
hey guys how are you doing great how can
john and i help
uh well um my wife just had a talk with
her mother what will be my mother-in-law
and uh during that conversation we found
out that she has like nothing safe for
retirement she's touching
and we're in the fourth quarter
and at the two minute warning
and we're down by like 20. so
i wasn't wondering
um
i don't know because i'm in a tough spot
i'm hoping to reach out to our family
members to see what kind of resources
they have
so we can help out mom um
and the only reason i'm concerning
myself with this is because like i know
if things go worst case scenario and you
know mom has nothing
we're going to be the ones to be taking
care of her you see the writing on the
wall prepared
yeah
um and so she
actually got a job that pays less she
doesn't have anything for her retirement
they've got a little bit of debt i think
they probably have
a truck which they're supposed to have
paid off by may
um a few credit cards which i have got
to get them to stop using but i don't
think they're out of control there's
probably like five or seven thousand
dollars in there hey will
um will yeah we will
brother
you're taking a lot on and i know that
you're looking down the road and seeing
that you're gonna be the person who
she's moving in with y'all is she
married
she's married yes okay
is it your
wife's
dad or is it a step parent or
that's my wife's mom and i know but
she's married
yes yeah and it's a step dad okay okay
okay so
here's the thing
you and your wife need to have a
conversation about if mom has a stroke
if mom
if step dad passes away if like when mom
retires when 70 80 years whatever you'll
need to have that conversation now
would we we did okay so the the solution
here is yes i'm not gonna let my mom be
homeless mom would move in with us if
she needed to
sure okay so you all have established
that
now i think you you walk backwards and
say
to mother-in-law and father-in-law hey
good folks here are some resources that
have really blessed our family
here's what i'm telling you you can't go
tell a 60 year old how they need to live
their life
they're going to laugh at you yeah
you know what i mean and so i you can
make resources available for them you
can
stay on the line i'll send you a copy of
total money maker that you can hand to
them right
you can give them resources
you can walk the talk you can
create boundaries if you want but if
your boundary is not going to be hey
either you all cut up these credit cards
or you're not moving in with us in 15
years when things go south
you hear what i'm saying like
you're creating catastrophe 10 years in
advance
and i want to give you some peace right
now all you can control on planet earth
is you your thoughts your actions that's
that's it
so how can you and your wife deal with
the financial reality that's coming in
10 years or 15 years you all can start
saving you can think about different
work you can
start saving up to buy your neighbor's
house whatever that's going to look like
for y'all
and
you can give them some resources and try
to be a good cheerleader but you can't
tell a 60 year old hey you know it's
about time you got your turn your life
around right
it's just not practical and you're going
to create more division than helping
will it already no um i mean we already
go ahead i was just wondering is is your
mother-in-law stressed out about their
money situation
or are you stressed out no
well they've been ignoring it is the
thing um like my mother-in-law actively
admits like the husband
does not manage money well uh he's never
taught how so i don't really blame him
for that and she was never taught how
and so
you know i'm over here thinking well we
do have some time to make some plans
and it seems like you know we literally
just had this talk yesterday so like hey
um we want to make sure you guys are
taken care of
um we have some plans are you guys open
to these plans and so
let me help you make some moves
and well the mom's very open we haven't
spoken to the dad not because we're
hiding anything from him but you know
he's got sons
and we don't want to feel like we're
stepping on their toes
but you know there's a family history of
just like you know um
money mismanagement
yeah so forget the toes brother i'm
taking care of my mom and her mom comes
with her husband so we're gonna sit down
have that conversation if if his sons
want to throw a temper tantrum about how
they can call you but man i'm stepping
on all kinds of toes when i'm dealing
that situation right now but you can
only control you man
it's a good word and there's no laws
against retiring broke unfortunately
john
do what you want in america free country
hey that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books our thanks to james
childs our producer ben hill on the
operating board there and kelly daniel
our associate producer and phone
screener we'll be back with you before
you know it america this is the ramsay
show
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermsyshow.com
[Music]
you